Đồng tên lưu Bốc gia sò thử tử tử chỉ phụ quyết định thành lập theo kêu định của Bộ lật láo đậu để thực hiện những trực năng tư vần cho chính phụ về mức lưu tử thiệu sắc lập theo bông, bảo vô mức lưu tử thiệu theo tháng và mức lưu tử thiệu theo dõi tưu.
Chỉ sách tên lươn, háb sốt lối tội người láo đậu theo kêu định của Bộ lần láo đậu.
Hối đồng có những Bộngin cửa khảo sắc tụ tập tình phần tích và đánh giá thình in tình lần mức sống tối thiệu của Mel đậu.
Sản xuất kêu dò anh của dưới nghiệp, quan hệ khủng cầu láo đậu được làm tất nghiệp trong nền tình tế và các yêu tổ liên quan khác làm cơ sở sắc lệnh mức lần tối thiệu.
Đồng thời sĩ sức bảo cao về mức lần tối thiệu của Mel đậu và gọi tất yêu tối sắc lệnh mức lần tối thiệu của Mụ lần láo đậu.
Già sốt mức sống tối thiệu của Mel đậu và gắn ra định với láo đậu.
Phân vùng địa bản áp dụ lần tối thiệu làm cơ sở sắc lệnh phần án điều trình.
Mức lần tối thiệu theo tình tế kì lấy kì hàng năm hỗ đồng tối trức nth thực lượng để khuyến nghiệp với chính phủ.
Phần án điều trình mức lần tối thiệu sắc lập theo vùng.
Mà hỗ mức lần tối thiệu theo tháng và mức lần tối thiệu theo dợ.
Nông thời hỗ đồng cũng tư và tính khuyến nghiệp với chính phủ về một số chính sách tình nân áp dụ trụ.
Đối với người nó đậu trong các hệnh giản nghiệp cơ quan tục trức ở tắc xả theo quy định của bụ lần nó đậu.
Lướng tối thiệu vùng đã được đường trình nhiều lần trong xuất đức nằm qua.
Nếu tối tối buồn tả mô thì mức lần tối thiệu vùng một lần tối thiệu vùng một lần năm phải phần nút trực đồng tắng.
Bung hai là bốn phải bánh bà chức đồng tắng.
Bốn bà là bốn phải bốn chiệu đồng tắng.
Bốn là bác phải bánh chức đồng tắng.
Mức lần tối thiệu theo dợ tại buồn tối là 2 mấy lần năng trắc đồng tối giờ.
And yeah yeah it's so good for all 3.
Bốn mỗi bánh giinh th瘑 trong đồng tối gone.